let me start by saying I've seen the
whole series and loved it
um I can't recommend this enough to to
for people to watch it's just very it's
very powerful and important
um for both of you uh can you both talk
a little bit about
um what it was about the material that
said oh I have to do this well
personally
I mean I think climate change is a
really important subject and I think we
are we're sort of bombarded with a lot
of climate information about what's
really happening in the world a lot of
data that doesn't really mean very much
to many people and so when art meets
life
um and data as it were math something
I'm not very keen on
and it's entertaining it's like a
no-brainer for me that was that that's
what I wanted to do it's like the
ultimate storytelling that has a purpose
for me that was it and also being made
by Scott Burns who he really knows how
to tell a story great writing oh yeah
um same thing
being part of the uh such an important
story to tell that needs to be told uh
to tell the audience that that it's
important to think about our future our
planet and and make their a little more
aware of
um of what's Happening Now and um that
there's still a hope that we can change
things
uh if we do it now and at the same time
as an actor to to just you know being
offered a part like this and uh and such
a beautiful
show uh being part of such an incredible
cast working with uh Scott especially
because uh my two episodes where we're
directing by him I didn't have that uh
the you know the honor to work with you
and Dira and the others
uh so I'm I'm really excited to see it
too because I haven't read the episodes
and I haven't seen them but yeah mainly
the topic and uh and selfishly as an
artist uh being part of the beautiful
you know compelling
show tahara I have to ask you an
individual question
um my favorite of the eight is episode
six which is one that um that you are a
part of in fact you are I mean it's your
episode essentially
um what was it like actually for you
reading that script because it's so
beautiful and heartbreaking and so like
it just feels real you know the
depiction of the future oh thank you so
much uh yeah you know when I first read
the script I I was amazed by the quality
by uh it was so obvious to me I felt
like really jumping in in the future
that it was real even if it's a uh in
terms of writing a fiction but it's it's
based on science and
and it was crazy to feel like a young
man in the future being
um you know
um affected by what
we've done in a way and it's just it's
he I mean my characters is not even
talking about climate change
is in it you know he's a victim of that
because he's got a illness and all and
and more personally
uh it was so challenging to play many
different roles and in different
languages and and that emotional Journey
that Ezra is going in was uh beautiful
because it's heartbreaking and at the
same time at some point there's hope
there's a light he's gonna meet somebody
the the great dimitron and then
I don't want to spoil right exactly no I
don't I don't want you to spoil anything
um uh uh but talk for both of you one of
the things that the series does so well
is it um it involves like real people
but also like people at the highest
levels of government trying to you're
sure you're seeing all sides of it
um can you and um uh you basically play
someone who is um I don't want to give
too much away but is uh willing to make
is willing to do things to try to help
the planet yes Gita is
she has power basically uh as a
billionaire you know
um and she
she's all she also has her own
motivation to
and reasons why she wants to
Save the Planet but she I think she
wants to play God because she has that
much power
it's funny isn't it because we're
talking about how the some of the themes
within this series is one of the themes
is greed it's like what motivates like
what makes us do something or not do
something and why are we doing that
thing and I think that is one of the
things that I find quite interesting is
to gita's own motivations within the
series definitely for both of you I'm
always curious about how things are made
in the behind the scenes so for soon to
be fans of the series uh what do you
think might surprise people to learn
about the actual making of the show um
hard question
maybe people would be surprised by how
much of it is real science
oh yeah I think that's quite shocking I
mean it's all it's all stuff that exists
it's all technology that exists now but
um
they have Scott has extrapolated uh what
might how it might be used or how it
might be developed in 30 to 50 years
time
um yeah I think that would probably be
shocking and surprising and hopefully
galvanizing Todd do you want to add
anything or I can move on
one of the things that I think is is
great about the show is it's one thing
to read about in the future people will
walk around with an oxygen mask and an
oxygen tank it's another thing to see
people actually doing it in a realistic
portrayal while also just dealing with
their normal lives and hopefully a
series like this can really impact the
conversation in our government leaders
can you sort of talk about the how art
can sometimes really impact the real
world but I think you've just put the
nail on the head really you've just hit
the nail on the head I think it's that
thing of you know often uh problems can
feel like they're happening elsewhere or
to other people uh if you're in a
position if you live somewhere where
you're not affected by climate change so
actually seeing it helps people feel and
then hopefully they'll realize that
stuff needs to be done and it's not just
the individuals we as individuals we all
need to change our lifestyles but it's
also it's also big like government it's
um big industry it's big business it's
we need to pressure them in order to
change as well and stop greenwashing
um you know all that kind of thing
and reduce carbon emissions
etc etc etc great exactly
well it was before I run out of time I'm
going to ask uh an individual question
for each of you um you're both in
upcoming projects that I'm very excited
about uh tahar you were part of Madame
Webb and I believe Ridley Scott's
Napoleon which is I mean I'm very
excited and India um you're part of Dune
The Sisterhood and uh some Mission
Impossible movie
um you know I've heard about that uh can
you both tease um your upcoming roles
and and these upcoming projects if you
don't mind
[Laughter]
I wish I could talk about you know Madam
will ever know all I can say is that
it's it's a beautiful story different
than what we've seen before and uh that
you're gonna love it as I did uh
Napoleon I can talk a little bit more
about him playing uh Paul baras who was
uh one of the five uh it was the the
most
um important and influential director of
the directory in uh and the post French
Revolution and he's the one who
discovered Napoleon
I've actually got something for Netflix
coming out called Obsession which is
essentially Josephine heart novel called
it's based on the Josephine heart novel
damage I don't know if you remember
there was a film Jeremy Irons and Juliet
binat in the 90s and that's being remade
well we remade it that's coming out
fairly soon that's quite fun totally
different to this
um and the other two science fiction
projects
uh well not a patch on this because this
is real science non-fiction I'm just
gonna say uh congrats on this it's
really exceptional work thank you for
making it and good luck with the rest of
your speed dating